Speaker 1: Donald Trump was asked finally about
Ron DeSantis possibly running against him and
more generally about Ron DeSantis. Trump's answer
is stunning and insane, and it is like that of a
mafia don of sorts. Trump appeared on the
water Cooler with David Brody. Of course,
Trump not appearing in visual form as he often
is literally phoning these in lately. Trump asked
about DeSantis. Here is his insane answer.
Speaker 2: I got him elected,
pure and simple. He would have never if
I if I said I wasn't going to endorse
you, that I you there was no reason
to go wild about endorsing him. He
was very nice in the sense of the Mueller hoax.
Speaker 1: The gist that is, that is a bunch of
spaghetti thrown at the wall. But it's it just
none. It's four different things. But the most
important there is. DeSantis won by 19 and Trump
barely mentioned the guy. Now Trump says, Well,
I endorsed him, but I didn't go crazy with
the endorsement. Trump specifically excluded
DeSantis from his final rally in Florida,
choosing to campaign only for Marco Rubio
and not Ron DeSantis. DeSantis won by 19,
even though the polling had him only plus 11.
Desantis's win is proof that Trump's endorsement
is worth a lot less than Trump thinks. Not a lot
more. And now Trump is getting all mixed up
because he knows what is potentially coming
in 2024 between him and Ron DeSantis. You know.
Speaker 2: He was one of about 100 congressmen
who voted for me. And so, you know, I felt I felt
I might as well endorse him because I didn't know
Adam Putnam, but he was a threat. He was ready to
drop out of the race. It was all done. Adam Putnam
had that nomination locked up, You know, the
Republican nomination for governor was he had it
locked up. It was done. And what I as Adam Putnam
said to me when I met him a year later, I didn't
know him at all, but I saw he said it was like a
nuclear bomb went off like a weapon went off when
you endorsed him and the race was over, he said
he didn't even spend his money. There was no way
he could have beaten him after I endorse him. So
here, now I hear you might want to run against me.
So we'll handle that the way I handle things.
Speaker 1: We will handle that
the way I handle things. By which
Trump means. Character assassination,
petty nicknames, name calling, maybe even
attacking the physical appearance of Desantis's
wife as he did to Ted Cruz. That's what Trump
means by will handle it the way I handle things.
And this could really be Trump's undoing.
Or it could be Desantis's undoing. Remember,
we don't know. It's not obvious that the Santos
can actually handle a national campaign against
Donald Trump. This interview was bonkers. Trump
then moved on to saying that he is fighting the
deep state. Trump is still fully on this
conspiracy stuff, saying he's he's got the
deep state against him. Folks, this is a former
president. This is equivalent to saying it's
the Illuminati who tried to end his candidacy.
Speaker 2: And, you know, beating the deep state
and fighting the deep state and winning you are.
And you can't just be a real I think I am a very
nice person. But if you are going to win, we have
to be tough and we have to fight back for it. And
again, I was under siege. Explain that to people.
As soon as I explain it, they always agree. Yeah,
basically, you have to fight back. And when you
fight back, you know, I want to fight to win. I
want to win for the country. I want to win for the
people. And, you know, I could see it Kellyanne
saying, well, he wasn't very nice, but I don't
want to be nice. These are people that are thugs.
They are very sick and very bad people. And if I
fight back, you don't sound as nice as you should.
Speaker 1: But Trump's the victim, guys. The deep
state is against him. Everyone's against him. He's
just fighting for what's his and everybody
calls him mean. What a victim this guy is.
Trump then weighed in on the border, and as is
often the case, made something up whole cloth
that is untrue. See if you can spot it.
Speaker 2: Here like this. This border is
a disgrace. And I don't know if you
know they're letting in prisoners,
but they're letting in all their people from
mental institutions, many countries letting
them in from there, emptying out their mental
institutions. Let me into the United States.
Speaker 1: They are emptying out their mental
institutions into the United States. This would
be on a Jeopardy category called Things That are
Not Happening. And this would be the daily double.
That is, of course, not happening. And it's not
enough to say they're emptying out their prisons
into the country, which is what Trump used to
say. You always have to become more hyperbolic.
So now it's they're emptying out their
mental institutions. TRUMP Lastly, then,
of course, talking about January
6th and says that he did absolutely
nothing wrong when it comes. January six.
Speaker 2: What about January six? You think
Merrick Garland is going to indict you regarding
January six? And what would be the fallout if he
decided to do that?
Speaker 1: Right?
Speaker 2: Well, I can't imagine
because I did absolutely nothing
wrong. It was peacefully and patriotically,
which they never talk about. Right.
Right. All of the other things that have come out,
we've done absolutely nothing wrong.
We I protested this day. I protest
that election. That election was a disaster.
Speaker 1: Right. And so what Trump is saying, of
course, is that the rioters were right to be there
because Trump really did win. And the protesters,
rioters and insurrectionists knew it. And so they
were right to be there. This is as dangerous as
you can imagine for a guy who lost, incited a
riot, is on the verge of being indicted and is
now running again. And one other aspect of this
interview that we're going to look at separately.
The evangelicals are not only turning on
Trump, Trump is turning on the evangelicals.